we had the greatest love story of all
bachelor time
yes we had tiara
i can't control my eyebrow and we had
barb
it's a dream come true this is your the
bachelor greatest of all time
season one episode one recap grab your
glasses
it's time for roses and roses
hello my darlings i have sunglasses on
for no reason but i do
have a reason for a season yes this vlog
is to tell you that we are bringing you
a roses and rose on sean lowe's bachelor
goat episode
so we filmed this weeks ago when it
first aired but at the time
we wanted to put the focus on this
interview that i did with rachel lindsay
so that went up instead
now sean low season is now rerunning so
it's a reason for a season and a rerun
so i hope you enjoyed this review
because sean and catherine are in love
and i love you guys
and also i love that claire's men have
been revealed the list of them
leave me your thoughts in the comments
below and know that i am with you and
now
back to regularly
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
and i'm wearing kind of a tiger king
print vibe because i've still got to
find some strength somewhere i've got to
find
a little escapism we have a beautiful
rose today okay
we're still supporting our local
vineyards this is from brave and maiden
here in the akali area and oh i've got a
new glass yeah
that's a heavy poor
oh this stem is not supporting this
weight i better drink some
[Music]
let's get to it all right so everybody
we have the bachelor grain is devolved
the greatest seasons ever and we are
starting with
i think what we all could agree but you
know if you feel differently let me know
in the comments below
is the greatest bachelor love story of
all time sean
lowe's season on which he ended up with
catherine judici a spoiler alert
but i mean they're on instagram so you
know we know we know and we're going to
get into
the suspension of disbelief on this show
which i found to be
quite interesting so sean is the only
bachelor in the history of the show
to still be uh married to the woman he
proposed to
on the show so it's the greatest of all
time
but you know do you agree you know with
the bachelor it depends on your
definition of greatest
do you feel the greatest is the most
love the most dramatic
we have different different definitions
that's why we're going to get different
seasons okay
i also if i'm moving weirdly i slept so
strangely on my neck and i just
this is all the range of motion i got so
camera one camera two camera one camera
two
camera one camera two camera one camera
two
oh i know what'll help with that
guys this is going down like water here
we go okay
what was comforting and wonderful is
that even though we don't have a new
season of the bachelorette or the
bachelor
we still are seeing the things we know
and love on the show right
he's like the perfect beach blonde
hottie we're meeting the women
we have a tiara the bachelor is sean
i don't know who that is but all i could
hear
when i heard her name was sierra
[Music]
so i just kept going tiara and you know
what
she lived up to that level of energy
didn't she yeah
not in the like talented fun dance vibey
empowering way of sierra
a different energy i'm done with this
conversation but a similar level yeah
he's sensitive and he seems very genuine
and we have a leslie murphy
now some of the women i do know because
they've stayed in the zeitgeist
leslie of course went on winter games
where she dated dean
which god that seems just wild at this
point doesn't it like how much has
changed you know and it's also
interesting you know to hear
what people said back then like leslie
murphy says
she's definitely gonna marry sean lope
i'm gonna marry john low
i am going to marry my mom she did not
no
it would be amazing if sean and i fell
in love
we have an ashley f we have a desiree i
know she became the bachelorette
great so you know spoiler alert she
doesn't end up with sean
i'm a hopeless romantic so falling love
would be awesome
you know we have a robin i don't know
her but she says she and shawn are the
perfect match
perfect match oh and we have a sarah
herron
love her she's also stuck around a very
inspirational human being
so we're getting the pace of this going
you know i'm figuring out this show
we're gonna see the highlights of night
one
ashley and her fifty shades of grey and
her booty dancing
and it's kind of nice it's like the
cliff's notes you know just the highs
and the lows
just the yeses and the nose some chick
who got out in a wedding dress
and another who made sean lowe very
uncomfortable
with some sexual uh tie work maybe you
can teach me how to use this later
remember you guys colton was the first
technical
literal virgin bachelor but sean lowe
was a born-again virgin bachelor though
we did not know
that about mr lowe when we were watching
the show
he did not reveal it until after the
bachelor
and now i'm learning we're going to go
on a different uh wait for it
journey of each love story
from the season that was memorable i i
gotta raise my glass to leslie on this
one
they were having this awkward are they
gonna kiss are they not gonna kiss
moment and shawn's like
what are you gonna do and she goes keep
staring
what are you gonna do continue staring
what an answer it's like weird but also
thank you
oh and then the bachelor is the gift
that keeps on
giving the producers knew they hadn't
kissed yet
so they decided to send them on a date
where they
had to create the world's longest
kiss ever like get it oh wow
[Music]
hold on let me reset myself
like guinness book of worlds record
longest kiss ever you're about to
attempt to set the guinness world record
for longest on-screen kiss i mean i have
to say
ew quick sidebar though i do think a
couple of observations that we're gonna
get out of all of this
are going to have to do with chris
harrison's
fashion is pretty special and on this
edition of our new
segment we have to ask why the [ __ ] are
you wearing that vest
everybody help us count down from five
four
three two one
yes
it's the middle of the day in los
angeles
it's hot outside why are we wearing a
vest three
two one we've got a kiss for more than
three minutes
we've gone picture in picture it's like
an instagram
layout for your photos but it's for a
kiss because this has to be an on-screen
kiss
so i'm gonna say everybody do not
absolutely not
no way no how refrain
from drinking for that entire kiss
[Music]
we gotta be here we gotta keep going
everybody because
sometimes things work out oh
god okay i can't drink the whole bottle
and now and now and
now it's time for
tiara so nice to meet you what's your
name
tiara so tiara i want a lot of these
girls to
get the boots she was clearly the
season's villain and
don't drink every time she was
manipulative
living with all these women is just so
hard it's torture in life i get what i
want
always i'm smart i'm ahead of
everybody i don't trust anybody here
like i don't understand
why no one gets that and it's like so
annoying
breaking down inside and holding it all
in and that is not fair
i can't be tortured like this i honestly
wish i was a fighter
i honestly do because i would beat them
out of these [ __ ]
so just talking about a few of the peak
moments
the babe fell down some stairs
whether on purpose or on accident is
unclear but what was clear is that
she yelled at the emergency responders
who were there to help her i just want
to be left alone
i don't want to go there it's not
necessary
so let me out of here wow
wow wow i said to my inner person
there's no way she can top that oh no no
oh wait wait wait boo boo's gonna get
hypothermia
so they went on a group date to some
lake
and they all jumped in in a polar plunge
kind of a moment and
all the other women are fine they're all
saying
that it was an amazing experience that
was absolutely insane
i felt amazing except
tiara do you guys have a towel please
she gets out of the lake i see tierra
just
folded over and she doesn't even look
like she's
responsive and oh don't drink for every
time she's shaking
don't drink for every time she's
freaking out
don't drink for every person who is
completely lifting and carrying her
into a vehicle
did you believe that tiara really had
hypothermia
during this time with him and then
and then and then the showdown with
ashley
when shawn shows up you're a different
person yeah girls are jealous
and i only have one thing to say to you
all
don't ever let anyone
take your sparkle
they said you have a sparkle they said
terry you have a sparkle
do not let those girls take your sparkle
away
we thought crystal nielsen came up with
the glitter
done that was glitter glitter well
before all that turns out
tiara was spreading the sparkle
actually i was never rude to you
straight stairs
raised eyebrow no good morning and you
know and then
ashley says that tiara's always giving
her mean looks and tierra says and i
quote
i can't control my eyebrows i can't
control my eyebrow i cannot control my
eyebrow
why not do we need to get her some help
like here i am
[Music]
oh and shawn is sending her home it
might be best if
you go home now and she says nobody's
gonna take her sparkle away
nobody will take my sparkle away and i'm
not letting that happen
oh and desiree's still here crazy about
your sister
crazy about a lot of girls right uh so
we find out things didn't go well in our
hometown sean center home and what do we
think of sean's decision here i wanted
to know more
did he send her home just because things
didn't go well with her family sean has
said that he is a man who really
prioritizes family that family would be
his first thing he would want to do if
he finds love and gets married on the
show
so is that why he said no let me know in
the comments below oh but you guys
you guys you guys we are not just going
to cover
the greatest of all time we are going to
check in
in real time and see how some newbies
are doing
aka san peter how have you been
i i've been good man and turns out he's
not sad anymore
now what i loved about this is that we
were treating it
as though it's a mystery who peter's
dating you have a new love
so don't drink every time chris harrison
treats it
like a mystery but you have a new love
let's officially reveal who this mystery
woman is
who is peter webber dating who has he
been
quarantining with i keep waiting for the
big reveal
you'll find out soon enough
it's freaking kelly we know that this is
this is my girl
what do you think of peter and kelly
being together
i have to say they're happy so i feel
happy
i have spoken to them about this i don't
think
that peter could have gotten with kelly
on his season
i don't think he had seen enough and
learned enough
i think he had to see what didn't work
and why in order to see
what could work and embrace that
i think the most important question uh
on the mind of bachelor nation
is what barb thinks of this and oh
barb's here
barb barb verb
give me a k give me an e an l oh
e y what do you get kelly barb you know
a former cheerleader
coming in with a little chant don't
drink for every letter of the alphabet
she said
give me a k give me an e l o
e y what do you think of barb's response
to all this
i mean here's the thing long story short
barb loves kelly and barb's very happy
that peter's with kelly
i love her i love her so much and i
think peter and kelly are happy together
so here we are so now we're talking
about sean and catherine
and this is where the greatest of all
time the greatest seasons ever
has some great questions for me one
woman will become shawn's wife
like we know shawn and catherine are
together
but we're acting like we don't know so
which woman will sean choose
because we're watching the show so
don't drink every time you suspended
your disbelief
which woman will be left devastated how
are he and his wife doing today
who is it it turns out shawn lowe's
season comes down to catherine
and lindsay so it's the finale and
lindsey definitely did not see this
coming she says
she's gonna get engaged today today
is the day i'm gonna get engaged she's
not we know that you're not lindsay this
is the toughest thing i've ever had to
do
they don't get engaged shawn breaks up
with her
my heart's leading me somewhere else
oh and the emotion is real don't drink
every time
shawn says he needs clarity and i've
been searching for clarity
and praying for clarity john says he's
in love with her
that's the hardest part i love you and
don't drink every time she says
it's okay
it's okay no it's okay it's okay
it's okay it's okay
now she wasn't saying it's okay
i'm just gonna tell the audience my skin
zipper broke okay
and all my clothes are chris harrison's
house i only have one pair of pants here
that i wore here today to film okay
and literally the metal of the zipper
broke in half so now my my pants keep
unzipping i'm not gonna lie i've put on
a little quarantine weight
who hasn't so my pants keep on zipping
and so that's where we're at
oh she took her shoes off
what a moment she thought she was gonna
get a proposal
he instead dumps her and she's like let
me
take off these skin heels that i'm
wearing on a beach for no
apparent reason cheers to you girl
cheers to her i'm doing good chris oh
and now here she is
seven years later hi lindsay
and turns out she's found love she's had
kids
you know i do think part of this show
should just be named she's
happy now this is going good though
great
it's gonna be okay
okay you had your shoes off
you're you're leaving oh and this show
is the gift that keeps on giving chris
harris and asked her about taking off
the shoes
oh and she said her feet were swelling
my feet had swelled
and it was hurting so bad that in the
middle of the breakup i was like listen
if you're not gonna get down on one knee
i'm taking these bad boys
off because you're not gonna break my
heart and my feet at the same time
and now it's the moment shawn
and catherine my pants are still zipped
great
catherine i want to spend the rest of my
life
telling you i love you so sean is gonna
propose
to catherine but don't drink for every
time
catherine seemed in full disbelief i
don't think
she thought he was gonna propose
catherine are you mad
yes oh my gosh oh my gosh
this is for real that's for real did you
think
catherine thought sean was going to
propose
let me know in the comments below and
now we're going to catch up with them
oh my gosh so many great memories they
are so happy
they are so in love their children are
so beautiful so like
let's just have a happy moment
because we need it
don't drink for every child they have we
have sam we have isaiah we have mia
they had a happy ending we're gonna be
okay
and that's where we're at everybody
bottom line
i am so happy to be back with you guys
again
i know that these times are weird i know
that they're rough
i love you and support you and
we're all gonna be okay okay
you can find me on instagram twitter
cameo truly send me a message you guys
and i will try to respond because i
don't want you to feel alone right now i
want you to feel
that somebody's with you and i want this
to be
a reprieve a moment of light-heartedness
so that we can have the strength to move
forward
on that note i'm here in my apartment
for the goats the greatest seasons ever
bye
[Music]
oh my god the skin zipper
girl can you help me out here help a
sister out can you watch the zipper for
me
what else are you doing you're in the
netherworld you're in limbo maybe i
don't know
just keep an eye on it for me keep me
aware how did you
follow me here
[Music]
you